et voici un autre aspect de cette flèche
chine décidé à tout faire pour gagner
les premiers rangs dans le monde il
s'agit cette fois de sport à quatre ans
des jeux olympiques et du régime
alimentaire et disciplinaires draconiens
imposés aux jeunes gymnastes elles sont
présélectionnés dès l'âge de 8 ans et
travaille six heures par jour
envoyés spéciaux jacques cardoze yann
moix allez debout les filles c'est là le
signal c'est l'entraîneur qui le donne
dès 6 heures elle fait office de maman
elle les accompagne du lever au coucher
du lundi au samedi les sept petites
gymnastes du centre sportif de pékin ont
intégré cet internat sport-études dans
l'espoir de rejoindre l'équipe nationale
des jeux olympiques c'est un peu ma
famille ici j'ai beaucoup de copines à
mes parents ne me manque pas à 8 ans
gines et ses copines sont programmés
pour réussir triés sur le volet elles
sont considérés comme professionnels la
discipline et la rigueur ça prenne tôt à
peine 15 minutes plus tard direction les
tapis un réveil musculaire machin basé
sur la tonicité
leavitt palace - bras pour ces petites
dont le corps n'est pas fort mais il
s'agit de se construire une carapace
musculaire pour prévenir les blessures
une heure et quart d'exercice répété à
satiété les exercices du matin doivent
leur donner plus de tonicité
à cet âge là elles doivent augmenter
leurs capacités physiques
la vie d'un gymnaste et très courte en
compétition de 13 à 18 ans la qualité la
plus précieuse c'est de tenir bon dit un
proverbe chinois
seule la souffrance mène à la victoire
en dix ans n'en est pas question de
grandir trop vite même la croissance et
contrôler ce maire de soif
au petit déjeuner un bouillon et un oeuf
ce sera tout jusqu'à munich
en général ça va sauf quand je suis très
fatigué parfois je ne peux pas retenir
mes larmes
en fait je pense tous les jours 24 kg
vite - tagro si l'exercice est au moins
aussi dur que les autres
le lundi matin le repas familial pèse
encore elles ont toutes un kg de trop la
solution est toute trouvée vont
s'entraîner plus et manger quatre heures
d'entraînement occupent les après-midis
parfois les soirées les chinois disent
avoir diminué l'intensité de leur
entraînement
ils ont banni le châtiment corporel
suite aux plaintes des parents mais
l'enjeu des jeux est trop important
le pays envisage deux médailles d'or au
moins en gymnastique
la petite chine doit intégrer l'équipe
nationale dès décembre prochain pour
motiver les troupes on forme déjà
l'esprit patriotique des futurs
champions la levée au drapeau est
réservé à l'élite
une façon de dire on compte sur vous
pour gagner vous êtes l'honneur national